exigen respuestas sobre sus seres
queridos tras el último motín en una
cárcel de Ciudad Juárez vengo a
preguntar por mi sobrino para ver ya que
hasta ahorita no se nos ha dado ni una
razón de ellos no tenemos ni no sabemos
ni cómo están y nada nada de él entonces
pues andamos preocupados Queremos saber
sobre nuestro familiar que nos hablen
que nos digan algo de ellos que dónde
están O si está bien Nomás Queremos
saber si está bien
verdad qué está pasando unas treinta
personas lograron fugarse del penal
ubicado en Ciudad Juárez ciudad
fronteriza con El Paso Texas en Estados
Unidos luego de que un vehículo blindado
baleara el centro penitenciario y causar
a la muerte de unas 19 personas diez de
ellas guardias hay muchas injusticias
verdad uno no puede hablar de ser tanto
pero pues
en verdad quiero hablar con el director
y pues
decirles a todos pues que nos apoyemos
en esto y pues aquí somos seres humanos
todos no antemano todos tenemos errores
y pues ahorita
queremos la oportunidad mucha gente de
saber de nuestros familiares la fuga
masiva incluyó al jefe de la banda Los
mexicles Ernesto Alfredo Piñón de la
cruz También conocido como El neto quien
ya se había fugado en 2009 y que fue re
capturado en 2015 los mexicles son una
de las principales bandas de Juárez y
las autoridades dicen que trabajaban con
el cartel de Sinaloa los oficiales al
retomar el control de la cárcel
encontraron una zona donde los reclusos
tenían televisores celulares y dinero en
efectivo además de drogas como cocaína
fentanilo y heroína el director de la
prisión fue despedido por ser sospechoso
de ayudar a la fuga el mortífero motín
del domingo es uno de los más violentos
en los últimos años en México